hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
judith jarvis thompson's article the
trolley problem
begins by considering an earlier
treatment of
similar moral dilemmas in philippa's
foots the problem of abortion and the
doctrine of the
double effect in which trolley cases at
least one of them is being brought up
in order to make sense out of the
permissibility or the moral requirement
to do or not to do something that has to
do
with causing death and thompson thinks
that
foot is very helpfully raising some
issues
but that her solution is flawed and
that's where she really begins
the article so we should take a look at
what thompson has to say
about this there are two original
problems that she considers
at the beginning of her paper obviously
foot had
other examples or cases for us to
consider but these
are the ones that she's primarily
interested in so that she can make an
argument about where we ought to direct
our our attention so one of these she
calls
trolley driver and the other one she
calls transplant
and if you look at both of these on a
surface level
analysis they seem to have a lot in
common
both involve a choice between
one person dying or five people dying
and if you put it at that level of
abstraction without providing any
details
then you know it it's pretty
straightforward we would maximize
utility that is we would try to
uh you know try to maximize benefit
minimize
harm five deaths is worse than one death
so we're going to side for
one pretty much any time but
the way in which the deaths are brought
about or
caused plays an important role so in the
trolley driver
she says um here's here's the case the
the trolley rounds a bend you're the
driver of it there are five track
workmen who have been repairing the
track
the track goes through a little bit of a
valley at that point the sides are steep
so you must stop the trolley if you are
to avoid running the men down
you step on the brakes the brakes don't
work so you're gonna hit these five
work people and kill them and
you can turn the trolley off onto a spur
of track leading off to the right
but unfortunately there's another track
workmen on that spur of track he cannot
get off the track
either so you're going to kill him if
you turn the trolley
on to him is it morally permissible
for you to turn the trolley that's the
original
trolley driver thing you are the driver
and you have to decide go
right or continue on kill one person
kill five people the other case that she
brings up
is transplant and she says
you are a surgeon a truly great surgeon
among other things you do you transplant
organs and you're such a great surgeon
that the organs you transplant
always take at the moment you have five
patients who need organs
two need one long each two need a kidney
each the fifth needs a heart if you
don't get these organs today they will
all
die if you find organs for them today
you can transplant the organs they will
all live where to find these organs the
time is almost up when
you find out a young man who has just
come into your clinic for his yearly
checkup has exactly the right blood type
and is in excellent health you have a
possible donor
all you need to do is cut him up and
distribute his parts among the five who
need them
you ask but he says sorry i deeply
sympathize but no
would it be morally permissible for you
to operate anyway
and in these cases people
according to foot she says rather
implausibly
that everybody she knows says it would
be morally permissible for the trolley
driver
to go off the the track and
kill the one person rather than killing
the five
and that everybody says it would be
morally impermissible for
the transplant surgeon to carry out this
operation
against the wishes of the young man
brought
in who has you know explicitly said no
and killing him in the process
putting aside the implausibility of this
absolute consensus
on these issues the question that arises
then
for uh thompson is well
why are these cases so different from
each other
he should she says here is mrs foote's
problem
why is it the trolley driver may turn
his trolley though the surgeon may not
remove the young man's
lungs kidneys and hearts in both cases
one will die if the agent acts
but five will live who would otherwise
die a net
saving of four lives so if you take a
very
strict utilitarian approach to it
leaving aside any other
side considerations like the more the
horror at carving up people who come in
for
checkups or anything like that and you
just consider it in terms of
maximizing uh utility and saving lives
well then it seems kind of a no-brainer
why are these cases different is it is
it squeamishness is it
some irrational thing on the part
of human beings and
foot's solution to this is to say
that uh look the surgeon's choices
between operating in which case he
kills one and not operating in which he
lets five die and killing is
surely worse than letting die so this
distinction between killing a person
letting a person die is an essential
part of this
and thompson says okay we can come up
with two basic
principles here that are operative
in these cases for foot and and what are
they
the first one is that killing one is
worse than letting
five people die and we'll come back to
that in just a moment
the other one is that killing five
is worse than killing one and you know
that one seems
pretty straightforward you know you
don't have to be
a utilitarian to buy into that do you
you know killing
five people is worse than killing one
all things being equal
the question about killing one is worse
than letting five people die
that's probably a more
controversial idea
some people might say well like you know
again a strict utilitarian would say
it's all death it's not really mattering
that much what the agency of this
is but i think most people would go
along with saying
yeah i mean if we if we raised the
number to like
a hundred thousand killing one person
versus a hundred thousand okay then the
we might get different results but
killing one versus letting five die
okay so she says here
in the piece um
here we go the surgeon must refrain from
operating
why because killing one is worse than
letting die
by contrast the trolley driver's choice
is between turning the trolley
in which case he kills one and not
turning the trolley in which case he
does not let five die
he positively kills them he's the one
driving the trolley that runs
them over so the question is which of
these two
basic ideas is going to apply within the
case and this is what allows us to
differentiate them
apart from each other this is the
solution
that that foot provides according to
thompson
thompson then raises a problem and this
is where we get the
now traditional trolley problem
where you have what she calls the
bystander at the switch
instead of you being the trolley
operator
you're just some person who's wandered
by
and you see the trolley out of control
bearing down on five people
you see a switch that you can flip and
if you do flip that switch it directs
the trolley
onto the other set of tracks and there's
one person who's going to die
there nowadays we see people more or
less tied down to the tracks rather than
just
being work people and all that and
she says that in this case
we would actually think about it
somewhat differently
she says what to do
here's the switch which you can throw
thereby turning the trolley yourself
you will kill one if you do
but i should think that you may turn it
all the same it's morally permissible
she says my own feeling is an ordinary
person a mere bystander
may intervene in such a case if you see
something
a trolley a boulder an avalanche heading
towards five
and you can deflect it onto one it
really does seem that
all other things being equal it would be
permissible for you to take charge take
responsibility and deflect the thing
whoever you may
be now why is this
so important is this just a little tiny
change in it
not exactly because what this means
according to thompson is
that the bystander
in the trolley problem now becomes much
more similar to the surgeon
in transplant who is
killing one or who is not
who's not to kill one right in the the
trolley problem
that's been transformed into bystanders
of the switch they are killing one
and they're doing that instead of
letting five die
if you're at the switch and you don't do
anything you're not
causing the death you're not running
them over the trolley is running them
over
you have the option to flip the switch
why is it okay in the case
of the person with a trolley or as she
says
in other similar situations like
boulders
avalanches things along those lines
why is that okay but it's not okay
for the surgeon to take this young man
and
dissect him and transplant the organs
isn't it really the same thing and she
says
well this raises a
key problem for us and she she does have
a few other considerations right she
says
we can take a moral risk in doing these
things we don't actually know all the
case it could be that the five are not
track workmen at all but
mafia members in workmen's clothing and
they've tied the one work man to the
right hand track
and she says i don't have to worry about
these possibilities because
you know moral risk is the same whether
you're a trolley driver or a bystander
and she says we might also want to ask
ourselves what exactly is the difference
between
what the driver would be doing if he
failed to turn the trolley
the driver is driving the trolley into
the fire but what does that actually
consist in
he's just sitting there and he has no
control over it
um that's comes to seem a bit more like
killing one to save five
doesn't it um
then she says uh i don't mean to make
much of the fact that about what the
driver's driving is trolley into the
five would consist in
it seems to me right to say if he does
not turn the trolley he does drive it
the trolley into them but it's not easy
to say what makes it so by contrast if
the bystander doesn't throw the switch
he doesn't drive a trolley into anybody
but the bystander may intervene
and she says if he can if that's
morally permissible there is serious
trouble for
mrs foote's thesis it's plain that if
the bystander throws a switch he causes
the trolley to hit the one
and thus kills the one it's equally
plain that the bi if the bystander does
not throw the switch
he does not cause the trolley to hit the
five he does not kill
the five he merely fails to save them he
lets them die
so in a case like this it seems like
killing one
isn't worse than letting one die
according to what most people would say
our moral intuition so
what should we make of this that's the
question driving this piece forward
you